foreign ergy bills are climbing
but they're still far from their Peak
and at this activity center in Exeter
many are already anxious I think this
winter is going to be frightening
um I live alone I've got a plan with a
friend who also lives alone if we need
to we'll go half time in each other's
houses leaving one house cold for a week
Helen is an intensive care nurse and
worries about the impacts on elderly
people who fall at home they won't come
in alive there'll be a 90 yard who froze
to death in their home it's appalling
it's appalling when they come in alive
on the brink of
on the brink of death it'll be appalling
if we don't get them in because they're
already dead on the floor those poor
paramedics
and those poor people
everyone here seemed to be feeling the
pinch it's now a huge portion of my
wages every month
um
means less available for especially in
the summer holidays for taking kids out
holidays basically it doesn't matter
what provider you're with it's expensive
and people just simply can't afford it I
think we're going to get to a point
where people have no choice
that's exactly what kierstama is Keen to
avoid elsewhere in Exeter the labor
leader has been launching his 30 billion
pound plan to freeze fuel bills
but critics argue it isn't targeted and
subsidizes everyone including the
wealthy sakistama how much do you earn
I earn just over 80 000 as an MP and I
own more than that for being lead with
the opposition so in total what's that a
year about 130 140 000. can you afford
to pay three four thousand pounds of EF
energy bills yes but the program I put
in place today is a program to ensure
that the price increases that are
scheduled for this October and for
January don't take place at the moment
the price cap is at just under 2 000
pounds in October it's going to go to
three and a half thousand pounds and in
January to four thousand two hundred but
you've just said you can afford you
could afford many many households are
impacted by that I've been talking to
people here in Exeter from all sorts of
different backgrounds with different
incomes the point they are all worried
is the level isn't one of those
households do you understand your
critics who were who were concerned that
you are not targeting support and
instead some very wealthy people
including yourself are getting this
government subsidy which is costing 30
billion this is across the board because
many many households are impacted by
this it has the massive benefit that it
doesn't allow the price increases to
take place in October and January but it
has another benefit which is really
important and that is it reduces
inflation by four percent because it's
across the board the energy price cap
has risen from 1200 to almost 2 000
pounds in recent months that's what an
average household pays per year Labor's
freeze would save families from what's
coming next predicted increases to three
and a half thousand pounds a year in
October and 4 200 a year by January on
the key side some agree with Labor's
plan actually the government should do
well they should cap it shouldn't they
they should stop it are you having to
change what you're spending because of
that yes I won't be down here
go into the office or coffee Etc yeah I
should cut back a bit yeah
kirst armor is playing catch-up on
energy bills the liberal Democrats and
SMP have already announced their support
for freezing the price cap but labor
have set out far more detail on what
they do than either Rishi sunak or Liz
truss one of whom will be tasked with
tackling this crisis in just three weeks
time
more support from government is highly
likely because tougher times are on the
horizon Joe Pike Sky News Exeter